welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section and also the next one we
talk about electromagnetism
electromagnetism is not part of the core
of a20 we are not requiring
electromagnetism and electromagnetism as
part of the prerequisite i will not test
or include electromagnetism in the final
but nevertheless it's interesting to
discuss electromagnetic effects in the
context of special relativity as there
led to the development of special
activity in the first
after all the paper which describes
special the theory of special relativity
is about
the electrodynamics of moving bodies and
so let's have a look at the
electrodynamics of moving body
and so here we have a source
a charge which is moving with a velocity
v
and moving charges or currents create
magnetic fields you can use your right
hand and see
particles are moving in this direction
here the electric field lines are
curling around
good so now i have a second charge a
test charge which is moving with the
velocity u
that test charge will experience a
magnetic force the force is equal to the
test charge itself q t
times u cross b the velocity across the
magnetic field
all right so there is clearly a magnetic
force acting on this charge
in this reference however if i now move
into a reference frame where the source
charge is stationary
a stationary charge is not creating a
magnetic field so the magnetic field is
zero hence the magnetic force on the
test charge is here i can alternatively
look at the reference frame in which the
test charge is stationary and so also
here because u is equal to zero the
magnetic force is here
so clearly we do have to treat magnetic
and electric fields
instead of a consistent matter as we
treat time and space and energy momentum
in a consistent manner so we need a
concept of electromagnetic fields and
previously in this class we look at
electromagnetic fields light on before
the difference here is and that's
context of the next section is that we
want to understand how we create those
fields how we can create electric and
magnetic fields and how this all works
together
at the first activity i want you can to
consider the cube of length l
with n electrons if n charges inside and
everything is at rest
and what i want you to figure out is
what is the charge and current density
wrote not and j naught
of this cube
and the second step as you can imagine
i ask you to consider the very same
thing from a moving reference frame as
prime with some velocity u which is the
velocity
um
of s prime with respect to s
what is the charge in the current
density now in this new reference frame
okay i'd like you to figure this out
okay so now we look at this
cube
and the total number of charges is n the
length or the volume is l naught cube
and so the density is n divided by l
naught q the current is zero nothing is
moving there's no moving charges current
is zero
all right this was rather
straightforward but now in our moving
reference frame the situation changes
here
one of the direction the direction in
which we are moving is lawrence
contracted so we have lx equal to lx
naught or l naught
times
divided by gamma or times square root 1
minus u square over c squared the volume
then
of the same cube in the
s prime reference frame is in a cube
divided by gamma
the number of electrons however is
unchanged so the charge density
is the previous charged entity divided
by the volume and if you
if you compare
sorry the charge divided by the new
volume which is
the um
density times gamma
for the new charge density
we simply have to multiply the mutual
the current density
for the
current density we have to multiply the
charge then t times the velocity and
again we find
rho naught times u
times gamma
okay good so if you look at those
relations they look very much like the
relay relations between the current and
the density charge density they look
very much like the relations we had
between momentum and energy and time and
space and lauren's transformation look
very similar so we can
motivate it by this
uh write a four vector which is the
first component theta c times the
density
and that's the first second and third
component
the
current
and you find that the invariant here is
very similar to time in space energy and
momentum
given as the density
where the charges are at rest
and that's in the invariance and you can
calculate this for multiplying
the four
often squaring the volume
okay so concept questions
is the electric charge conserved on the
lawrence transformation
but did we actually change the charge so
we have the charge density here and the
current here but did we actually change
the charge on the lawn transformation
the answer is no we did not change them
so
the charge is conserved or the charge is
invariant on the launch transformation
is the electric current conserved on the
lower dimension
or invariant on the lens transformation
it should rather use invariant
and the answer is no it's not so we have
seen from the very first example that we
start with the current zero and then in
the s prime frame the current is of a
certain value so certainly the current
as seen from two different observers
you